Lord Mountbatten was the son of a man
named Prince Louis of Battenberg and
they were German immigrants and Prince
Louis was the first C Lord that is to
say the senior professional officer in
the British Navy when Churchill became
First Lord of the Admiralty and then the
war broke out with Germany and he had to
resign and then they changed their name
to in their relations of the Queen from
Germany you know in the first world war
will end yeah so the the Kaiser Kaiser
bill Kaiser William Villa the second and
the Czar of Russia they were victorious
nephews and she she wrote him as William
Nicky and you know and then they went to
war and killed half the world and many
Britons anyway that so there is all
connected right and in the 20th century
there was a kind of Saveur severing of
relations you know because they were
killing each other and Families don't
get along when they kill each other and
and and and Prince Louie a mountain burg
bat nerd was a great man a loyal Britain
but he had to quit because he was German
and so they changed the family name to
mount bet and these people are all you
know related to the Queen not Benton was
the last governor-general of India he
was a commander in the same theater
where where McArthur commanded for the
United States in this you know in the
Asian theaters and and you know he rose
to be chief of staff the British
military is his last service in the 60s
well he was killed by IRA terrorists and
what year 79 I should know that
yeah and members of his family children
were killed in a they blew up a boat he
was on vacation the IRA and you know
Britain then proceeded to kill a lot of
them which was only right anyway that's
that's all there right and now if you're
looking at that if you're standing in
the horse carts Brighton you're facing
tin
10 Downing Street go to the left and you
get to 11 Downing Street that's what the
Chancellor of the Exchequer lives and
then that whole complex all the way down
to Whitehall Street those are executive
cabinet executive offices so there's a
cabinet and meeting room in there and
there's offices for the senior officials
who serve the cabinet especially the
secretary of the cabinet there's a very
important man during Churchill's but
most much of Churchill's life the
secretary was Norman Brooke and he was a
heck of a guy
very good he's the one who after
Churchill was defeated he was writing
the Second World War and you know he he
got he got paid amounts to the by the
time it's all paid you know something
like 20 million dollars for writing that
and so Churchill became
well-to-do for the first time in his
life and was he going to get to use the
cabinet papers and some of that is in
the next of the last document volume and
not the one we just finished but the one
before that because Churchill is
corresponding with him a lot and and you
know they you know the Labour government
they whipped Churchill good and they
politically they really dislike each
other and there's a few that personally
really dislike each other
but Churchill loved most of those guys
because they were and in fact Ernest
Bevin who was the foreign minister in
the Labour government Churchill himself
brought him into politics knowing he was
a left-wing socialist because he was
this Union guy and he was tough as nails
and he organized labour in the Second
World War
so they're all getting on right and
Churchill's having to write them letters
and say any I want to use these papers
and of course it's going to be famous
right everybody in the world's gonna
read this book and then it comes up in
the cabinet when it's announced what
Churchill got paid by Henry Luce and in
Britain very large amounts to and all
over the world they wonder if we should
have
no government you should get a piece of
that and and you know and we have the
records of the discussion it's very
civil and they vote unanimously no you
know and and that's because it's my
point after 1940 Winston Churchill was
the greatest man in the world and what I
mean by that is that's how everybody
treated him if they opposed him they
still opposed him but they altered to
have they did it to take account for the
fact that he was the greatest man in the
world
so and urine Bevin a different Bevin not
Ernest Bevin
he was very left-wing and he was a great
taunter of Churchill but he's also the
guy who caused some of the most
significant honors to Churchill and and
when it came time to speak words about
Churchill and his achievements he was
one of the best although Clement Attlee
was way the best so so that that all
that happened there right and the reason
they made the 28th meeting where the
whole cabinet was invited was moved to
the conference room in the in the House
of Commons in the Palace of Westminster
was because there's going to be more
people there and it would have been
crowded and for once Churchill wanted
everybody there not crowded and but you
know mostly those meetings all happen
there and they those meetings still
happen there although most of the
treasury is located somewhere else now
because we live in the age of big
government now if you if you go keep
going turning left and wheeling you know
so you're facing 10 Downing Street you
go like this that's the society the
Horse Guards Parade that faces Whitehall
and that's a long stretch that that's
called Dover House and Penny and I just
looked it up the Scotland offices are in
there and then that gives way to the to
the left hand as you're facing Whitehall
Street to the left hand the end of it
that's where the Admiralty begins and
there's a brown brick section that faces
white all straighter than it abuts a
section that comes off at a 90 degree
Ingle and that brown bricks a section is
where the First Lord of the Admiralty
lived they don't live there anymore in
fact I learned a couple of years ago
that what's up in the cuz you know it's
very nice house and and you know
Churchill lived in it quite a lot
because he did that job twice what's up
in the top now is that cabinet ministers
maneuver to get close to the Prime
Minister because they let it out to
cabinet ministers for periods of time
and then they've got a really great
address in London and that's kind of
handy although the Grand part of it is
public now they don't put people in
there live I'm told and then the part
that goes into the 90 degree angle from
Whitehall Street dad that is the that is
the traditional the old Offices of the
Admiralty which is was was the greatest
military force in human history up to
its time and those antennas there was a
marvel of Technology because they could
meet the Admirals and the sea Lords and
they can run the Navy and they could
communicate with any ship anywhere in
the world
right out of those antennas and you know
they were relayed to places not where
but they had a very sophisticated system
and and that's and see in former days
which were better days if you looked at
that place you thought nobody can resist
that that's too strong you know that's
where Nelson came from and there might
be more of them you know and Britain had
these three two generals and a sailor
and the thing about them was they were
just completely lethal they just never
fought anybody they didn't win that's
that's not fully true of Wellington who
how because he mostly fought from
weakness and delayed and stayed in the
Iberian Peninsula and Portugal and
eventually Spain because it was hard for
the French to get troops over there and
that meant they'd get a few over and
he'd bleed them for a while and then
they needed to send more
and once Napoleon tried to break the log
jam by going along the coast this
quarter and skirting the southern end of
the Pyrenees and the British Navy came
up and just destroyed vast numbers of
troops with cannon fire so they couldn't
do that anymore anyway those three guys
those those three guys more than anybody
else they made you know they won the
military victories that made this the
seat of power in the world so that
Admiralty thing is really great and and
if you if you look when you go back if
you're looking at the Admiralty look up
to the left and behind it and there's a
statue standing up there and first of
all that Street
it's kurzon Street is one of the best
addresses in the world but you know Lord
Curzon lived there and the statue is of
him is that right Richard do I remember
that right and there's a great story
I'll tell you about him he was very he's
very capable man very pompous man - he's
very noble and so Churchill said of him
once very indicative of Churchill's
opinions people style Churchill is an
aristocrat he was born high but not high
enough to get either a title or money
and he eschewed the principle of
aristocracy so Lord Curzon said famously
once and Churchill turned this into a
great devastation
he said the upkeep of civilisation is
the work of aristocracy and that's how I
talked and Churchill said it would be
truer to say that the upkeep of
aristocracy is the work of civilization
and they said in church of goes on he
says see he understood the literal
meaning of that word because Ariston
means best and arcane means rule or
ruling principle democracy that means
the rule of the tens the rule of the
many right aristocracy means the rule of
the best Churchill says I bet there was
not a Marquess or an earl who didn't
delight in those statements by Lord
Curzon he said but he did not mean real
Eckerson to aristocracy he meant he
meant the rule of the well-born not the
most talented not the bravest not the
most gifted right Churchill said
democracy is the fellowship of us all in
the leadership of the best democracy is
aristocracy in other words and that's
exactly what the founders of America
thought too so so then and all that
surprised later to tell them two great
stories about Lord Curzon that are just
awesome
the second is less awesome but came
later Lord Kherson waited in his house
there on that great Street and waiting
because they were having a cabinet
meeting and they're gonna come ask him
to be Prime Minister and they never got
there and he was disconsolate but
another time and Churchill draws a
picture in an essay he wrote and
published later in great contemporaries
about Lord Curzon he broke many great
sketches of people he knew and they're
just wonderful to read a little bit like
Plutarch's lives and he tells that story
and Curzon's frustration and pacing up
and down but the better story is a bunch
of cabinet members came into his house
one time and they were scheduled to have
a talk and he was very distraught and he
was pacing up and down and somebody
finally said what's wrong with you my
lord and he said my gardener has left me
and they said well you can get another
gardener and he said but do you know
what he said to me no and he said I
asked him why he was leaving and he said
because you my lord are a son of a [ __ ]
I messed up his day you know so that's
what all that is
and you know it's it's it's it's fun if
you go anywhere with Martin Gilbert you
learn to do this you never get one
guidebook always get to and they'll have
different information and he would if
you go anywhere with him
he loved to walk and he walked in jerks
and then he was suddenly stopped and you
wouldn't move again until you'd figured
out everything that happened in that
place in human history and mostly he
knew you know if he flew on a plane he
always got the window seat and he always
watched and he always sent notes to the
pilot about what we were going over and
what happened there and so if you're if
you you'd be on a plane that he was on
and the pilot would start giving this
guided tour of history
so do you have any questions yes sir oh
yeah sorry it's uh I have an AED and I
make a virtue of it
so that's military governing force
London and the greatest in the world
and so the reason they do least the way
they do it I mean first of all the
cavalry you know that was an awesome
extension of arms Churchill was a
cavalry officer he took part at Omdurman
in the Sudan in the last big cavalry
charge the British ever had and his life
was saved he said because he'd hurt
himself getting on an on or off a boat
and he had a bad shoulder and he was a
big-time polo player and it changed how
he played although he was really good
and so he couldn't swing a saber very
well and so he used a pistol and you
know because and they at the battle
armed him and they they actually
launched this cavalry charge thinking
there was only a few but the desert is
fools you because it's be depressions in
it you can't see and they go over a rise
they didn't know was there and they're
just a huge force and they got to cut
their way through it well and the point
was the cavalry that was that was the
fun you know Alexander the Great
conquered the world by the first vital
use of cavalry that was his innovation
he he made big fat war horses brave and
he charged the center of the line
wherever it was he found the worst place
and he charged it and he broke through
and then he turned in both directions
and he just cut the enemy to pieces and
he eaten it over and over and over again
all the way to India
anyway so that's the cavalry and and so
the infantry guards Buckingham Palace
and the tower the cavalry guard the
Horse Guards Parade and and that
ceremony what it means is the guards
their sentries and they can be there by
themselves and and that way you know if
there's an attack they'll get killed and
the alarm will go up but then they don't
ride solo back and forth they are
escorted by a larger force because there
might be an attack at any time and and
so that ceremony what it is is is coming
to get the ones that are there and bring
in the new ones and escorting the old
ones back and you notice that two things
you notice that the columns because they
have different functions the the
probably sergeant I don't actually know
in charge of each column they bark
orders in answer to one another to
coordinate the force and then if you
watch closely you'll see the horses know
the commands and so every time when
there's a big command after a silence
some of them will move too quick because
they know what they're supposed to do
and one of them at this time it'll be
it'll be embarrassment one of them
actually started he stopped him and then
the course of stopping him he turned a
circle right beside the sergeant the
worst thing that could happen so that's
a you know and it's it's ceremony but
you got to remember it has a lethal
derivation and all of those people are
cracked troops and they can fight and
they're good with weapons and so that's
what they do and yeah so that's what
that's about
do you want to say something sir
urban legend or true so do you hear that
yeah shut up Richard yeah
so the question is was an urban legend
or truth that Churchill got somebody to
go give his speeches and the answer to
that question is yes let's just say it's
either urban legend or true so some
parts of that are true in summer false
it is true that they didn't record in
the House of Commons until 77 yeah and
yeah Penny's nice beautiful little girl
now he's got little girls her own she's
always been very well-spoken and the
first thing she learned to speak were
animal noises but then Fiona what does
the pig say if she could and what does
the speaker say because this is what
they said when they came on a BBC in the
morning while she was having breakfast
to go to school on the radio it starts
with the part of the summary of the
parliamentary debate starts with the
speaker's like order ordered you know so
that little girl could do that to a tea
yeah it so the the allegation by I mean
well qualified to be called jackass was
he said that he gave Churchill speeches
that it was yeah yeah yeah what
oh yeah but even broadcast them on the
radio no and and so the thing about that
is first of all most of them were not
broadcast on the radio some of them were
awesome you know they you know blood not
blood 12s this way but the first one the
next week after he came prime minister
that was you know if necessary alone if
necessary for years you know it's very
beautiful but and some of those were
meant for broadcast when he rebroadcast
the speeches that he'd given in the
house there's evidence that he was bored
by that phenomenon and he and and people
who heard buzz both especially Harold
Nicolson who kept a diary so people who
keep really big Diaries tend to have an
influence how will you understand in
history because you got the diary but he
didn't give them as well and you can get
recordings of all of the ones that are
recorded and you'll see that they're
like more and less lively and but but
some of the ones that were not so lively
that if you listen to them or many like
that for me and I'm disappointed you can
go find what people wrote about him who
heard the same speech in the House of
Commons and even Nicholson in particular
you know Churchill was one of the
testimonies to his rhetorical power was
people like Nicholson and people like
Hugh Doulton who kept the best notes of
Churchill's speech about May the 28th
1940 they just loved him didn't agree
with him about anything but he was the
best show in town and and and so there
was huge attention on him and then if he
gave a radio talk and it wasn't very
good and they'd been telling all their
friends you ought to hear this guy and
then it's a little little flat so
there's records of people
but no that guy didn't do that and we
know I didn't do it for a lot of reasons
but one of them is there's lots of
testimony of people who watch them and
you know they sat and watched him do
them and a great one and I can't
remember the date Richard may be well
but she really had a great friend in
violet Bonham Carter and she was the
daughter of Herbert Asquith the prime
minister and she's the grandmother of
the actress Helena Bonham Carter and she
was a very beautiful woman a liberal by
party persuasion and Churchill and she
were very close friends for a long time
they got a little sweet on each other
for a short time but they were just
really friends and Churchill's way of
courting women until he learned better
was he would memorize Marshall Faulk
poems with you know that didn't work but
he did that with her and there's one
very famous one by Arthur Hugh Clough
say not the struggle not a valence I
haven't memorized I'll say a line or two
say not the struggle not a valence of
labour and the wounds or vein the enemy
faint not nor fail us and as things have
been they remained so you see it's not
don't throw up your hands and then if
hopes for dupes fears maybe Liars it may
be in the smoke young smoke concealed
your comrades chase even now the Flyers
and but for you possess the field well
he man goes on there to mourn yes I
think I can do them all he says cracks
in inlets making
I can I can almost do the third one I
have trouble that one but the fourth one
is and not by Eastern Windows only when
daylight comes comes in the light in
front the Sun climbs slow how slowly but
westward look the land is bright now
that's perfect you know for a speech
that Franklin Roosevelt's gonna hear you
know Churchill was very capable man but
when he finished that speech he called
violent all right she said she was
sobbing she said did you hear our poem
oh and she said and you know that was
what that was 40 years ago that he'd
memorized that poem with her so that
jackass whoever it was did not give that
speech yeah about time gotta go gotta go
work snap to
[Applause]